up tonight we welcome as loose Lewis
icon visiting assistant professors Tom
coward Daisy fraud Vincent Lacavera and
Jeffrey share Croft who practiced
together in London as agents of change
with that name I couldn't resist
inviting them I have to say the con
visiting assistant professorship brings
young architect educators to our school
offering them the opportunity to lead an
advanced studio and a seminar the work
of the con professors as well as that of
their students is then published in book
form in 2010 negotiated terrains
documented the work of the studio's led
by Jeanne yang sania bald and marks
Aramaki in spring 2011 turbulence
documenting the work of the studio's led
by al Rahim Chris and bill Sharples was
published and later this fall
architecture inserted will be published
documenting the work of the studios led
by liza fuhr and katherine clark of muff
mimi wang and eric bungay of n
architects and Chris Perry of servo
agents of change is a multi-faceted
practice founded in 2003 permit me to
quickly sketch out the accomplishments
of its principles to date presenting
them in alphabetical order which they
have chosen not to sit in Tom coward
graduated with a BA in architecture from
the University of Nottingham in 1998 is
that true and with ons we don't we don't
mention that here all our guests are
honorable in 1998 and then went on to
the royal college of art where he
received the MA in architecture and
interiors in 2002 and thence to london
metropolitan university
where he received an additional degree
in professional practice in 2005 Daisy
fraud a trained facilitator graduated
from st. john's college at the
University of Cambridge in 1997 with a
BA in modern and medieval languages
before going to the Institute of
linguistics Educational Trust to receive
a professional the lump diploma in
italian to english translation in 1998
she concluded her formal education at
least to date with studies at the
University of London School of Advanced
Study from which she received an MA in
cultural memory it's not right in 1998
or you got the MA in 2002 2002 sorry
somehow I got that muffed Vincent
Lacavera is a 1999 graduate of the
University of Cambridge receiving a
master's in architecture I don't know if
he got on zor not before but continuing
his education at the royal college of
art where in 2002 like Tom coward he
received an MA in architecture and
interiors before going on to
metropolitan universities program and
professional practice I hope you're
following all this because you're going
to be tested on it Jeff share Croft is
like Tom coward a 1998 graduate of the
University of Nottingham where he
received a BA in architecture like our
damico vara he went on to the Royal
College of Art receiving his degree in
2002 and then breaking into new academic
territory share krav attended London
South Bank University to receive his
degree in professional practice it's
always a rebel in every crowd agents of
change is part of a small but highly
vocal and reasonably subversive group of
young architects in London who are
stirring the pot by at the same time
revisiting post-modernism and
challenging the bland neo modernism of
the current generation of English
architects represented by Tony frettin
Adam Caruso
st. John and others whom they along with
the partners of fat and muff have taken
to call the whisperers it's much tougher
in England to be an architect while it's
easy to assess where agents of change
will take architecture I for one admire
this statement of purpose which I a
quote in part aoc is committed to
exploring and enriching the relationship
between you and the complex messy world
around you aoc is about making things
some of these things are buildings not
all of them though aoc is about making
things happen working with people rather
than for them it's now my pleasure to
welcome AOC this terms Lewis icon
visiting assistant professors as they
delivered tonight's lecture sampling and
synthesizing carry on I'll sit with you
can we trade oh you want the aisle
horrible thank you for inviting us to
come here I don't think ever and will
never have an introduction quite like
that Tom days even and I established a
SC on a premise of participation above
it in every stage in architectural
process would create better buildings we
wanted to work with our clients with our
builders with our end users and not for
them we wanted at the time we did not
know what processes or tools would allow
us to happen what forms it would create
all the implications would have upon the
subsequent use of the buildings three
architects and interpreter we had very
different interests in a subject and
different experiences that suggested it
warranted further investigation but we
were optimistic there are different
skills could and would combine to create
a fruitful exploration despite there
being many reasons for our individual
and shared interest and participation
there is a clear lineage with our
architectural history for considering
participation not surprisingly given the
events at a time much of the groundwork
for a participatory practice was laid in
the 60s in toward making places Charles
Moore critiques a chaos of
self-expression that our formal object
buildings of modern objects are created
and our architects to consider the
significance of making places co-author
donlon Linden goes on suggested key part
of this shift from providing form
objects to creating inhabitable places
is to let the user in not as a hapless
occupant filling a chair in the living
room or giving scale to the elevation
personal favorite vases but as an active
participant the user must be allowed to
participate reclaim through his acts
that which has been abstracted from him
here you can see they're much cited
example of the potential richness of
users being empowered by a distinct form
the gets of the Ganges providing an
infinitely adaptable base for activity
five years later viewable a student and
rest of six th gen Colo decarlo of tmax
made his case team tenth made his case
for an architecture that was developed
of uses not for he believed
participation needs to transform
architectural planning for New York
authoritarian act which is
being up until now into a process this
process begins one the discovery of the
users needs developing a brief
developing a proposal to the formulation
of formal and organizational hypotheses
making a formal proposal and three the
phases of use actually looking into the
inhabitation of subsequent buildings now
these two views from different side of
the Atlantic clearly defined a perceived
problem gave a clear call for action and
yet remember each two small but
significant audience yet forty years
later we have found few examples of
architects who have been able to either
translate these intentions into
appropriate buildings or describe a
suitable process for participation some
people have explored a literal
interpretation of participation which
the users of drawn proposals or dictated
to architects exactly what they want
this is not what we are referring to by
participation because it seems to deny
the potential of a mutually beneficial
relationship between user and designer
earlier in our practice we gave a public
lecture in which we presented our
intentions to create a potted
participative architecture the talk
prompted one journalist to label us as
the hunch bunch full of ideas of hunches
for what might be but with just few
examples to test our ideas intended as a
critique by its author this seemed an
entirely accurate way of summarizing our
position at the time as a newly created
practice standing here eight years later
we're now would you speak not only of
intentions but of real experience we
have designed and led participative
design processes that have led to
realise projects we have delivered a
number of buildings predominate in
London including schools and homes
museums and exhibitions permanent
Foley's and temporary theaters this is a
school we're about to complete in three
weeks time in South London we've even
been able to enjoy watching some of our
buildings being inhabited in use adapted
and misused now this experience has led
us to having an increased clarity about
what a participative process can be and
provided us with examples some of which
we hope to share with you tonight it's
in many ways we still approach every
project with a number of hunches to
explore inherent within a participative
process is a commitment to creating the
appropriate process for each
revolving appropriate forms for each
brief and for accommodating appropriate
uses for each situation we aspire not to
have a house style nor a predetermined
formal solution nor even a predefined
process looking back over our practice
it becomes apparent that a technique is
sampling and synthesizing has been a
constant useful device for creating a
participatory architecture now we've
always been drawn to work of architects
that seem to continually ancient
practice of sampling synthesizing sown
luncheons venturi sterling to name but
for we've attempted to learn from their
approach and began to develop our own
techniques for designing in this way
more recently we have looked to other
disciplines to find a contemporary
conversation regarding the what the how
and the why of sampling synthesizing as
a productive method for not only
considering formal proposals but also to
design development and subsequent use
its 2001 book post-production Nicholas
Borya outlines a significant shift in a
production of culture throughout the 80s
the democratization of computers and
appearance of sampling allow for the
emergence the nuke invoke new cultural
configuration is emblematic figures at a
programmer and a producer the remixer
has become more important than
instrumentalists the rave more exciting
than the concert boreal uses a
contemporary evolution of music culture
to suggest a new role for the artist the
role of remixer rather than creator
enabler rather than giver working with
rather than working for this seems a
similarly useful model of which to
reconsider architecture and a role of
the architect but considering people as
active producers rather than passive
consumers we might reimagine our role as
architects as more akin to a DJ than a
singer-songwriter carefully selecting
existing elements putting our efforts
and to synthesizing them together to
make new combinations most importantly
creating an atmosphere in which our
public's can participate responding is
appropriate to the change in character
have in common an extensive element of
brief building both preceding and
overlapping with the design development
process as most of our projects are in
some way public with complex networks of
stakeholders and potential users this
can be an intensive and resource heavy
activity and is always designed bespoke
why do we make that investment at all
levels functional symbolic and
experiential we believe that we get a
better end product through really taking
time to understand the needs and desires
of our users by better we mean more
specific more rich more appropriate more
accommodating and more responsive it
allows us to bring together to
synthesize our own expertise and our own
likes and interests with the unique
knowledge a--'s and experiences and
tastes of our clients and users to
produce something that could only be the
result of that conversation this picture
above is taken from a submission for a
project where we mapped the cultural
histories of all the different
stakeholders including ourselves and
looked how that might come together into
the built proposal this is what British
architect and theorist Jeremy til
paraphrasing American planner John
Forrester calls making sense together we
liken that process to a successful act
of interpretation with the same balance
of careful attention to context expert
knowledge of the possible tools grammar
and materials to hand and faithfulness
to source material combined vitally with
an unfaithfully creative imagination to
paraphrase Umberto Eco resulting in
something in which all of our influences
can be recognized and recognized
themselves and yet that is more than the
composite of its parts that stands alone
as an artifact it's the difference
between Google Translate which maybe has
more in common with some earlier
participatory architecture practice with
its reduction of the
tect a facilitator and celebrated Irish
poet seamus heaney's translation of
Beowulf the original narrative the
manuscript is captured translated and
transformed into a new and authoritative
piece of work in its own right that is
both deeply familiar like the chainmail
on the front cover and yet that opens a
whole new perspective on what has gone
before so how does this commitment
manifest itself in projects well partly
in the fact that not all of our projects
as Bob said a building's a significant
proportion of our work is about
designing interpretive frameworks or
tools that allow non professionals to
make sense together when thinking about
the future sometimes that may lead to a
built proposal other times a change in a
pro sure in investment a Cedric Price
said the answer is not always a building
one example of this is the building
futures game that we were commissioned
to make by the Royal Institute of
British Architects in 2006 it allows a
diverse group of people to explore and
play out possible future scenarios for a
neighborhood scale area making them set
priorities evaluate options and then
propose specific visions for debate this
built on an ongoing interest in gaming
and game design do as Rafe Costa the
Sony game designer said in his book the
theory of fun to the potential of their
structural and formal properties the way
in which games offer as in this
illustration by Lewis Carroll abounded
terrain in which different possibilities
can be tested and conflict productively
managed through a shared understanding
of the rules in more theoretical
language they offer what political
theorists chantal moof might call an
agonistic space as opposed to the
consensual one that many participatory
processes tend to move towards too
quickly all games we have created bring
together and adapt familiar elements
in the case of the building futures game
it's Top Trumps do you have Top Trumps
in the state trump cards you're missing
out they're very simple cards cards with
values for different things so you might
have a colorfulness 6 wickedness 5 and
then you weigh up your cards and you you
try and beat other people by pitching
against them and if they have a lower
card than you have the value you pitch
you get the cards very important
complicated snap so in this case Top
Trumps and we also bring together
familiar processes so that professionals
and non-professionals have a starting
point of a shared level of expertise in
the material that's literally at hand an
initial shared language that facilitates
the production of further shared
frameworks of meaning now the building
futures game itself developed through
multiple iterations it was designed
collaboratively these are all the
initial worksheets through workshops
with real communities looking at real
places throughout the UK and our design
studio this one's in Swindon this type
of work says something about our name
although we only ever publicly present
ourselves apart from in Yale as the more
anonymous aoc which can mean anything we
want it to as the slide above shows aoc
did originally stand for agents of
change and this refers both to the
setting up of a dialogue that's at the
heart of all our projects which
references the idea of artists as agents
of change that lies within the whole
Boise and Joseph voices social sculpture
project but it also refers to the idea
of a chemical agent of change what we
ask is the smallest yet most active
contribution that an architect can make
to affect productive change when for
example in a board game helped generate
a landscape our 2007 project to design
the lift a mobile meeting and
performance space to accommodate 200
people for a
in theater production company was a
highly collaborative brief building
project but did require us to produce a
building the client asked us to work
with a dozen community groups of all
ages backgrounds and abilities
representative of its constituent base
across East London to design the
building over a period of months three
creative workshops with each group to
produce the brief where we worked with
artists and these were delivered based
around storytelling and craft based
activity that's just a few of the
hundreds of artifacts that these
produced all telling stories about past
experiences and future stories of the
possibilities of this place was followed
by the formation of a building
development group a core group guardians
of the brief who worked with us to
detailed design now the challenge to
this process was that in order to win
the competition we had to produce an
object-based proposal at the start in
isolation this was clearly rather odd we
couldn't just then forget our idea and
the client was keen that we didn't but
we had to find a way to build a brief
that was not afraid to challenge the
existing concept proposal as well as
building on it a second challenge was
condensing and fairly combining the well
considered views of all our participants
into one brief now the original document
not here is a lengthy palimpsest of
different fonts and colors to allow all
voices to be accountably traced prior to
the act of synthesis in the design
studio but this chart is something that
was given to participants to sum up the
process that they went on so they could
see where they've been what the other
groups are done and what had happened to
their ideas developing our spatial
Constitution was one way of starting to
move that towards a designed form common
to many of our projects a spatial
Constitution brings together the
priority ingredients the design
Commandments if you like into one place
and through an act of collage starts to
express these in graphic form
it offers a shared reference point for
designers and future users and acts as a
tool that empowers the non-professional
to hold the designer to account and to
challenge us so to sit there saying you
cannot tell us that this design is cozy
something that people might feel scared
Norma later to say to the architect and
that helped make this into a shared
project a large scale priorities event
delivered on a low budget using prosaic
object such as tents and shower curtains
allowed us to bring all participants
together for both practical testing and
to explore some of the design issues in
depth to explore where limited resources
should be targeted and a debate element
such as how much power the user should
have to be able to change the building's
form the result on the inside a
landscape that could quickly change from
epic to intimate through the lowering of
deployable structures at a touch of a
button that a child can operate and from
daytime meeting space to black box
performance space through the drawing of
curtains on the outside a building that
has much in common with our competition
scheme but he's also fundamentally
different perhaps most obvious is the
addition of a window developed after a
comment from a nine-year-old participant
in the course of a building design group
design review all participants agreed
with him that the lack of direct
daylight and views of the sky in our
initial proposal was not appropriate the
kind of space that we've now
collectively imagined into being and
when closed by night this supports a
cinema screen below from a symbolic
perspective equally important is the
pattern on the outside this was a hot
potato as we say in the UK throughout
the process and debated at length with
the building design group how to create
something that could speak to all its
potential diverse audiences no one
thought the building should be white too
many connotations of corporate Marquis
but what
in the end a free quilting pattern
called best of all with squares colored
in by multiple hands and then
synthesized into one expanse provided
the answer its domestic connotations and
intimate scale against the scale of the
building offered the homely qualities
that had emerged as so important to our
collaborators but that was only one
reading of this multivalent material for
example one muslim member of the
building development group told us that
to her the skin was redolent of the
patterns of islamic art and so on the
spatial Constitution provides a
springboard between a design process and
formal proposal there's still a certain
amount of work required and something
and synthesizing as we said is a
technique we use very much for that
stage but a problem is it for last 100
years I hasn't mean much conversation
amongst architects about how you sample
how you synthesize so I'm just going to
prevent a quick snapshot of some other
voices talking about it sterling mr. TS
eliot reminded the mature poet differs
from that of the immature one not
precisely in an evaluation of
personality not being necessarily more
interesting or having more to say but
rather by being a more finally perfected
medium which special or very varied
feelings are at liberty to enter to new
combinations 1922 another spatial
constitution for a hearth house which
you can see later it's a reoccurring
thing how can you bring together new
combinations of very familiar objects
gowda ball 1956 the literary and
artistic heritage of humanity should be
used for partisan propaganda purposes
any elements no matter where they are
taken from conserve and making new
combinations anything can be used it
goes without saying that one is not
limited to correcting work or to
integration diverse fragments of
out-of-date works into a new one one can
also alter the meaning these fragments
in any appropriate way not idea of
appropriateness is very much dominates
our conversations and talking about
what's appropriate sample and how to
synthesize it I mentioned Lutyens
earlier just an example of the optimism
and speed with which architects
previously synthesized he
areas taking the second story of st.
Paul's Cathedral to make the British
school and Rome he then lashed on tube
at the back of that a tuscan villa and
then for the art studios copied the
Royal Academy art studios that amazing
speed next arity produced something
completely weird and wonderful in a
different context is something we very
much take as a starting point taking it
back to Joyce but in 1992 introduction
by debt considered Ulysses is therefore
constructed on the understanding that
Styles like persons are interchangeable
the method no not quite Dadaist
intermittently justifies Joyce's
accountant himself as a scissors and
paste men we are definitely citizens and
paste architects only Joyce could have
written Ulysses and yet it is a book
which asks us to give serious
consideration to the possibility that
anybody could have written it there is
something that's really interesting that
sampling and synthesizing in that
although obviously you choose what
sampled and new synthesized by using
familiar elements you yourself drop back
slightly the hand of a designer is not
so dominant I think Daft Punk really
nailed that in this quote from 2001
incidentally yes they are wearing robot
helmets no one really knows what they
look like when you use a sampler nobody
plays in it's a problem that the ego of
the musician is not really there for
everything that we do no matter how you
get to the results important thing is a
result so this process of sampling and
synthesizing I think it's a practical
art I think we get close to it the more
times we try and do it so I'm going to
take you through a little romp through
some of our projects which will
hopefully explain some of the ways we've
tried in the past this first project is
a temporary exhibition that was located
in Trafalgar Square it was for the mares
green homes initiative which was trying
to help homeowners in London find ways
to cut their carbon emissions and it was
a combination of a shopfront and a
billboard providing a 24-hour exhibition
space in Trafalgar Square
so what was sampled in this project they
simply was my own home but the phone
call rang one day and I had to turn up
two days later with a proposal of how to
put a terraced house in Trafalgar Square
and I was currently also trying to do a
bathroom conversion and loft conversion
in my house so it was at hand and how if
the simplest synthesizing came with how
you put a public gallery space or a
white space into a very domestic rail
and then how the the exhibition elements
can sit within that composite realm I
think what came out of that project
though as seen in this image is the kind
of amazing power of placing a
domestically scaled volume in a very
public publicly scaled space the second
project I'm going to talk about very
briefly is an a competition entry did
for the victorian albert museum called
retreat which was a temporary pavilion
that was proposed for the garden of the
museum of childhood in bethnal green and
here what we sampled were a few things
one was a something two things taken
from the site the the cruiser Sinjin
entrance pavilion facade but also the
trees in the background and a mutation
from one to the other the other perhaps
more interesting sample was a myth or
something that wasn't built the proposed
curators house that was supposed to be
included as part of the original build
of this site and how that curators house
for us became a space for storytelling
which was at the heart of the brief we
worked very simply with a plywood
structure and wanted to use paint to
inscribe a transformative space and the
internal space the external space
mutated from the cruise this engine
facade of a flat stone facade into a
Glade of
or a field of trees but once you passed
into the interior you came into a
slightly more charge space where we used
force perspective to kind of roll
reverse the roles between child and
parent and challenge the status quo so
used false perspective to change one end
of the room into a child space adult
space and the other into an adult space
that made them feel like a child so the
children the adults could play under the
table and the and the children could
tell them off from the other end of the
table very very slightly as a kind of
simple material method I guess this is a
small piece of work we've done on an
ongoing project for Charles Dickens
primary ski of school we're quite
literally we've transformed the kind of
graphic of Charles Dickens as an idea
for a school which is located in the
environment where Charles Dickens grew
up quite a while ago into a into a
signage or branding element for the
school and I guess its role is that it
is slightly suggestive in that it sits
within a field of signage that is
largely out of date due to the original
Victorian kind of splitting of infants
and children and boys and girls and
teachers on the site there's iconography
and signage that's when out of date
Charlie dicks and to that story this is
a project that we did for the Royal
Armouries in Leeds we went a won a
competition to transform the existing
foil foil a space of the museum what we
really found pulled in this project was
the content of the collection its
richness and its craft and we try to get
the the collection much closer to the to
the visitor as they entered the space
what was synthesized was the uncovered
in situ concrete that laid beneath the
peeling pink plaster and its mass
combined with the graphic likeness of
the gold leaf and paint the gold
animating the darkest parts of the lobby
and the paint relating to the collection
museums branding branding strategy for a
navigation here you can see how elements
from the collection in terms of shield
he'll jury was brought into the gold
leaf and to the visitors our reception
desk the next project unbuilt was a
second-place competition scheme for the
restoration and regeneration of the
Victorian Pleasure Island on the west
coast of England we proposed a hotel and
a timeshare resort for a suburb of
Western superamerica burn becky and and
the hotel development was supported by
some mainland commuter housing what we
sampled here was a found nature the
vegetated Rocky Isle in the Bristol
Channel but also the idea of fake
mountains whether they inspired by
Disney or by rock climbing walls and we
were interested in the thing for the
facade is a thin skin of vegetable
growth what we sink tonight synthesized
was that that juxta vision juxtaposition
between the occupation in homes and
hotels with a kind of touristic use the
combination of the homes patios
promenades broad walks and hilltop hikes
and how both by living and walking
around this object you would be brushed
up against that thin nature and the
occupation of our nature by animals and
birds made up close and adjacent Jeff
touched upon a project we currently have
on site at the moment which is an
extension to spar school in bermondsey
it's a special school for autism
secondary school what we attempted to do
with this project was really solve an
urban problem
or a town scape problem through the
various design sessions it was
identified that really there was a there
was a task in bridging the gap between
the articulated form of the original
London board school on the right on the
right and the flat curved form of the
more recent sports hall was on the left
and simply we tried to work between
those two shapes in an urban istic way
and bring something that brought a whole
to about that streetscape and facade but
what that gave us internally through
that urban response was a huge benefit
to the educational use so we were able
to provide generous and you need two
unique classrooms with traumatic ceiling
spaces in the heart of the scheme
there's a communal stair place and also
off that's there this it's a drama room
which opens onto that stair and opens
the building up that way but also serves
as a stage to the main PE hall where the
whole schools parent population can meet
to watch performances the building it's
located in a conservation area which
requires a careful relationship in terms
of how the planning process develops and
a consideration of the adjacent bill
form and how new buildings can be
accommodated within that fabric
externally the facade plays between the
flatness and depth of the two adjacent
facades but also materially and tonally
work strongly with thee and the London
boards for adjacent
another project touched upon earlier is
the architecture foundation where we
came third in a competition for this
project so welcome able to execute it
unfortunately but it was for a new
architecture center in Bank ride on
London just south of the river
understood in our mind as a new public
house for the house for the built
environment with general generous front
door that would invite new publix in
what we sampled was the urban scale of
the surrounding city a kind of unique
part of town which had quite large
changes in scale between little gem
buildings and also larger development
around and in fact that the context to
the proposal was for very large new
office building which is touching just
behind the tate but also some of the
townscape or street spaces that exist in
London innings in this particular
example we found a kind of scale
register with Sicilian Avenue but we're
also interested in this building having
a having an entrance that was somewhere
between the the generous shop front and
the generous public house
I guess a literal collaging of some of
those examples brought together
suggested how we thought the public
realm could be could be made we were
interested in making places to rest and
places to gain information places to
meet and the way that came together was
in a generous public stare that went
around the outside of the building up
onto the roof where we had a secret
garden so we were interested in how
through thee for the internal and
external stairs people would be invited
into the building at every level and the
building as a whole could be kind of red
as a self-seeding landscape the last
project is half house again which jeff
spoke about briefly half house we were
employed to remodel the interior of a
1930s semi-detached home in Golders
Green which is in Northland what we
sampled was the arts and crafts home
some of the things that were inside it
were had a texture and a quality that
the client was interested in the the the
mother that the t-shaped plan itself was
quite interesting and I guess
fundamentally quite modern in relation
to the arts and content but the family
were very keen that we found a way to
respond to the new needs of themselves
so what we synthesized or one of the
element we're going to talk about in
terms of synthesizing is a new stair
that was created at the center of the
house and the new stair was developed by
the use of appropriate styles on each on
each level the new stair expanded the
the existing stairwell opened opened up
the space in the centre of the house
right up to the roof and each story was
used very differently the sorry the
ground floor stair was formed from
institute concrete it formed a generous
half at the bottom of the stair but also
hard at the center of the house it was
made it was made warm and comfortable by
an extension of the underfloor heating
system into it but also by wrapping the
floor
Park a pattern onto the surfaces of the
concrete and the board barking of the
concrete formwork above thats there
opens up a Georgian or a mock Georgian
staircase the stair parts at the middle
level and ascends and generally that the
expression was fought through the use of
generic moulded balustrade which were
actually the most cost-effective way of
forming a handrail but also combining
that with a senior's hardware hardwood
handrail that goes up all the way up the
building the upper floor which serves
the private bedrooms of the building was
concealed behind a solid plastic hand
rail which we then laser cut with the
inverse of the generic Georgian but also
with lamp openings for local generous
lighting where we're needed along the
route the loss there above was set
further back and made more light and
transparent as a modern and metal
expression of the staircase the
different responses were then unified
together as an active synthesis in color
with three coats of white which brings
the stair back together as one
so this air I guess I heart health sums
up the interest we have in not only
sampling synthesizing to create a formal
proposal formal building but also the
subsequent relationship with the user so
this shot here shows how the clients
furniture pictures knickknacks animated
space as much as the efforts we've put
in to start with this is something
that's been an ongoing theme in a
practice since we began partly as a
reaction against called it rammed down
our throat and Nottingham which you
heard earlier we went to once our
professor said the word corpse 64 times
in one lecture but called therapy being
the highlight of that nature but the
Cubs seem to be very keen on controlling
things such great architecture is to put
in order but what an order function and
objects what's the early call we mean
I'd say obsessed with his scheming
pessac 92 and six housing scheme in
South France and suburb or Bordeaux in
which he arranged number of suburban
dwellings very carefully composed modern
boxes but over the years they've been
modified so people have filled in the
strip windows because they wanted
somewhere to put their bookshelves at
the end they put plant pots on the
outside they've kind of put Mexican
Pablo star the effects on it they put
some crazy paving down a column now all
of that would suggest cord was gutted
about this really upset but is it's
possibly interesting that maybe he
designed exactly the right thing because
he allowed them to make these fantastic
adaptations the quote that we kind of
possibly sums up exactly what we aim to
do by de certeau from practices of
everyday life our research squadron has
concentrated above all on uses of space
on the ways of frequenting or dwelling
in a place on complex process of the art
of cooking and on many ways of
establishing a kind of reliability
within the situation is imposed on an
individual that is of making it possible
to live in them by reintroducing into
them the
plural mobility of good goals and
desires an art of manipulating and
enjoying part of our work developing
proposals for a housing scheme for a
competition a few years ago we developed
this highly complicated matrix from
straight lace to fancy free which was a
kind of touchstone crossing in trying to
explore those types of housing which are
either run from either being so so
specific that they stop any kind of
future manipulation by future
inhabitants to those homes or houses
which somehow offer enough flexibility
to enable those future residents and
future owners to manipulate and sample
and synthesize to their heart's content
at the scale of furniture were supposed
types of furniture and manipulation of
space in the residential environment we
visited Lego town a couple of years ago
and we were interested it was around
Christmas time we were interested in how
these relatively generic repeated house
types their generic repeated front yards
expressed a hope and a variety of
Christmas decorations and festive
festive furniture of some form or
another which seemed highly highly
specific to the different residents and
an expression of the identity of those
individual residents there's only sort
of 20 minutes later when we walk to home
depot on the on the edge of Levittown to
find the shelves full of all of the all
of the specific inflatables and
Christmas decoration so everyone had
gone to the same place in order to find
their way to sample the stuff that they
needed in order to make their specific
mark at the scale of a house we've been
interested in how
particular types and in this case the
typology of the typical English
semi-detached house accidentally seems
perfectly designed to accommodate not
only those manipulations at the scale of
furniture but full-scale
reconfigurations additions
transformations extensions to the extent
of the kind of the kind of manipulation
that we helped our client make a behalf
house which is literally removing the
innards of a house and rebuilding it and
in this drawing that we produce for the
same competition to the straight-laced a
fancy free diagram we started to pick a
part of a kind of fascination we had
with this with the semi-detached house
the typical cookie cutter English repeat
repeated module of residential
accommodation and how it over time
there's a kind of typical story that you
could tell although it's obviously
different every time about how the
garden the back garden initially
designed to be the right correct size
for growing enough fruit and vegetables
to sustain a family becomes the perfect
environment for bouncy castles or for
kind of japanese-style terrace or
whatever you like now the front garden
initially designed as a kind of a
showpiece in order for a family to keep
up with the Joneses is accidentally
exactly the right size for parking
parking up a couple of cars or growing a
huge fish
this is exam an example from last year a
resident of one of these typical 1930s
semi DS was aggrieved with his neighbors
so initially initially built a huge
concrete wall around the edge of his
front and back garden the local planning
authority forced him to take these down
and his response was to grow this huge
bush and in this instance a relatively
generic-looking semi such house on the
inside houses a full-scale replication
of the Palace of Versailles obviously
these things are quite funny but at the
point that we show them is not it's not
really not as a joke I mean the
wonderful thing about the so many such
house is that it can accommodate all of
these various different manipulations
changes in expressions of identity and
can subsequently be removed and
something else can replace it easily we
have developed our in our fascination
with those types that the semi-detached
house in particular but other kinds of
building types and house to house types
in particular and have looked at how
what many of them share in common is
what we call suggestive spaces nooks and
crannies spaces that indicate or suggest
previous use or previous and habitation
and offer a way into future inhabitants
on the left hand side is an example from
a development by countryside properties
which includes a kind of change in
direction on the hallway that suggests
adaptation over time and on the right
the viola venturi house with the
staircase and this slide some similar
sort of condition where to planters
outside croydon Technical College are
perfect perfectly placed to accommodate
a homemade skype winning run which in
is only there for two days so how we
we've looked at some other examples of
how we've used a kind of what we've
called a spatial Constitution to unpick
what is valuable potentially with a
certain certain project in this instance
we use the drawing similar kind of
spatial Constitution drawing to identify
all of those aspects that we found we
considered every home needed and one of
those was the ability to change to the
ability to make changes to to to a home
and we've attempted to try to take those
value of those values and specifics I
suppose that are often you can often see
an example such as the sort of English
semi-detached house and apply those in
projects that we have undertaken and in
this instance this is a housing scheme
in Southwark in South London 45 family
houses which are called crown terrace
which where we attempted to accommodate
some of those potentials that are
described in the spatial Constitution in
particular there's a kind of robust form
to this to the structure that the ground
floor is masonry construction most the
top floor is the first floor is a sort
of timber box construction with
courtyard spaces and terraces at the
upper level which offer the potential
for future adaptation so you can see
here the courtyard space and the
terraces at the upper level which
provide that sort of potential for
change and for future use and misuse
that's slightly more urban scale we have
tested this as well on a competition for
housing scheme in Stonebridge park where
we
tested similar similar methodology ready
striking that balance between control
and freedom in architectural form which
elements can be designed to enable that
kind of future adaptation and what is it
that can be designed to help hold
everything together it's or Civic scale
in this instance pace or Civic Civic L
of elevation so in this slide you can
see that the elevation in green and and
pink Chevron's is the sort of civic
Civic element that holds the structure
beneath together but behind you find
there's a serious sequence of spaces but
unable adaptation misuse over time and
we Illustrated this in this case with a
lifetime of housing a lot of lifetime
homes idea a lifetime communities idea
so the same set of spaces could be could
accommodate a single professional a
young family or an elderly couple and
then we've we've tested and explored
this at the city scale as well in this
competition entry for an urban extension
to Nord nordhavn X industrial Docklands
which is it is proposed it will
accommodate a new urban extension to the
city our response was to look at the
potential the potentials of a grid as a
framework to accommodate potential for
change in the future this led us to
examining a number of different cities
that have the same climate and looking
at their latest of latent structure and
latent grid framework and how these
accommodated all kinds of variety and
multiplicities of urban form and we
we're also interested in how
same kind of framework could potentially
set up the basis for a narrative of
progression and growth of the city so we
we looked at this off the grids that can
accommodate the growth of coppiced
forests and how the forest as a metaphor
for the growth of a city could also be
genuinely useful in the building of myth
for a place and offering most
importantly offering ways into future
inhabitants and users of that place
which we summarized in this we called it
the outs of prog rock album album cover
for this project so the the sort of
progression of a planted forest offers
the potential for leisure but also for
productive landscapes in the
construction of both the myth of the
place but also the literal construction
of a new place new city and then that
framework then also provides provides a
grid in a framework of armature for the
the sampling of bits of Copenhagen so we
looked at all of the city blocks of
Copenhagen Copenhagen others of
characteristics of those and the
specific dimensions and the way they
worked and showed how as a kit of parts
as I sort of as a culture as a part of
copenhagen's culture they could be
sampled as a speculation they could be
could be sampled and replicated out on
part this grid to create over time a new
extension to the city so running through
kind of diagrams that indicate how this
might happen very simple ones a piece of
X industrial container dockyard starts
to get laid out as planted tree
plantations which are then
cut into to create clearings and spaces
for leisure and then over time offer
offer the kind of the opportunity for
the setting out of a new city
you
so that's kind of left from the scale of
someone sticking a tree in their front
garden to a whole city so before we get
to Meg limit maniacal I think it's worth
reflecting on why what's common between
those things and what's what's useful
and I think the thing that we refer back
to is this idea of the sampling of
familiar forms and I think when we we
did this at the project proposals for
nordhavn the important thing was about
setting out a potential a framework of
potential that could accommodate any
kind of suggestive form in the future
and that scale of this project which is
a another one of our school projects the
existing school was taken as the given
condition and through careful analysis
of some of the existing parts kind of
the these parts of the school actually
had huge amounts of latent potential to
be tweaked and interpreted in more
narrative ways to sue I supposed to
maximize or optimize their potential for
future use and misuse so in this
instance a kind of space left over
underneath the stair and Ernie thirst
air becomes a suggestive narrative space
or spaced of potential in the when the
building's been extended which soon
after the sort of the building that the
project was complete we were able to see
this actually working with space on
underneath us there had been transformed
into herself a play space that could be
interpreted in many different ways and
similarly a simple store for tricycles
which was designed in a way that meant
that children at the school could remove
the tricycles themselves meant that they
could then create create their own play
space within that cycle store
and in a similar way a building within
the grounds of the school that was a
sort of self-contained house small house
structure was designed to to fit the
scope this is a scale of of the children
at the school which meant that they
could take it all my suppose as they
wrote where we begin towards the
participative architecture something
synthesizing themes of a useful
technique in the development of a brief
in the development of formal proposal
and in allowing the user to engage with
the architecture at the end of the
process and ongoing really enjoy how the
user can change the space but also the
building kind of carries on impacting
user through time thank you very much
thank you very much it's nice to see my
youth coming back there are probably
some questions from the audience I hope
there are Eduardo hi thank you for for
the talk thanks for being so good at
communicating your ideas and maybe a my
question is about communication or about
the lack of communication because i want
to to share with you these concern of
this question about a sedgwick price and
the fan palace and you've mentioned him
and when you saw the images of the lift
I thought it will look quite similar
because I have this idea that in some
sometime around the 60s cedric prize a
harbour cam and other people who might
be related to what's being called
structuralism we're proposing these
things that will move around and you
could engage in a different way not only
decoration of the appearance but also in
the flexibility of these things and then
at the end with the grid a i was
thinking of our own thread cutter and
calling row and college city and i was
thinking I wanted to ask you whether I
cannot I don't know whether you already
discuss whether you wanted to go for a
McConnell type lego type of architecture
in with modular elements combined and
the user / consumer will engage with it
or you have considered that for the
future but I wanted to know why that
will be a road that you're no longer
interested in or you whether you would
like to explore that line
sorry Cedric price from palace I think
quite hear what yeah so the fan palace
and that kind of aesthetics of the
Meccan or whether you have considered
that as a project of engagement or is
something that you think is good at work
in your ideology or discourse some
palace was am very much a starting point
for the lift project some pastors
collaboration between a relatively young
architects edit price and Joan this
would avant-garde theater bridgie say
firmly believe that theatre performance
was a tool for empowering people and
cedric kind of began to suggest how that
might happen the scale of that proposal
was vast and didn't happen fifty years
later we managed to make a baby baby one
happen and when it first opened actually
opened about 500 yards from where the
original fun palace was intended so
there was a real feeling it was a
continuation that project but awareness
of why fun palace didn't happen partly
was about scale partly about a
commitment to engaging with credible
realizations of what it might be sort of
fun palace in a way was meant to be
formless it obviously had a clear form
and it's drawing we were very interested
in how you could create slightly small
scale project in there for more
deliverable might have a strong smaller
more compact memorability and work on a
number of skills as an object rather
than just being a vast space so that I
had a range of scales you can see it
from afar as one object up closer to
work sternly and then inside it was
surprisingly intimate I think that
relationship between something very big
something epic something very small very
intimate with what drove that project
yes
so I doesn't it chose me oh oh did you
want to add something Oh feel free
please no no no okay and Mitchell had a
question probably a two-part there's a
couple things that you are take a lot of
things you articulate I really
appreciate the talk and seeing it work
but I'm trying to sort some of the ideas
at myself one is that you advocating the
work and obviously the name of the firm
for change and you've stated two
contradictory ideas I think tonight one
is that you could take the core vision
stance of providing a neutral ubiquitous
model in which change will take place
over time by the very nature of change
itself rather than actually represented
in a single object or one could produce
a mechanistic idea of that allah price
in which the machinery then would allow
different changes in different
atmospheres to take place the other idea
more i would say venturi s is to
symbolize difference and change through
the collage of different elements and
then the question for me becomes in
terms of the techniques as designers how
you deploy those different ideas in the
work so for instance on a concrete
example coloring your work is
interesting because on some buildings
which are fairly neutral the deployment
of different color signifies differences
and in the apartment where there's lots
of different elements the weird
eclecticism that would be as neutralized
by white which is actually more
corrosion move so how do you make
decisions about which of these different
agencies of design you deploy in order
to produce changes it just is it real
change or is it just the simple symbolic
nature of difference or what is it that
you actually hope to accomplish in each
project with one of the problems I
referred earlier to an idea of what's
appropriate and working out what is
appropriate i would suggest is our
ultimate architectural ambition and
there are lots of errors that one can I
can get it wrong but I think it's that
conversation that drives us on and we're
getting closer to beginning to have a
sense of what's appropriate modern
situation and some of that is working
out the processes for
understanding a situation to try and
make an appropriate when that's
appropriate yeah and I would say and
this is perhaps why that we keep our
name under wraps because it can be
interrupted in different ways we
personally aren't necessarily trying to
effect change but we're trying to allow
for the possibility of change and we
believe on the whole that changes more
likely to happen through suggested forms
that might be interpreted in the way
that we in the original clients imagine
them or they may be completely
misinterpreted or misused um but I think
it that's more important not closing
down possibilities of change and
allowing I mean people who came to
who've come to the seminars that we've
been doing know that I have a slightly
further obsession but opening up the
possibilities of what ed soldier calls
third space or what lefevre would simply
say is lived space but where people are
able to take ownership in different
forms whether that's bodily or mental or
through memory and experience don't have
the answer and how to do that that's
quite possibly why when you when one
doesn't run through the work yeah we
have experimented in all kinds of ways
some more successful less successful
often depending on what the client is
interested in response but I guess
approach within appropriate answers
definitely a bow found condition rather
than either or as a general practice
model but also within most of the
projects and I guess I guess what you're
asking is well how do we how do you know
what you're doing or how does anyone
know what you're doing when you start a
project and certainly how do how do you
make a business out of offering up a
suggestion that will do the right thing
but we've got no idea what it is nor do
you and I guess the thing that marks the
difference between whether a ubiquitous
model is better than the mechanistic one
or
whether it's a collage whether its use
of color or not is just actually about
how how generous that offering is to the
to the situation so sometimes something
you're bit kritis is the most generous
thing that you could do and will be the
most the best way of spending the budget
and the best way of deploying material
on the site sometimes that wouldn't be
the most generous that would be that
would be taking something away from from
the users or the other future occupants
the space I think we often come back to
the term generosity and that is a
different word than appropriate us but
it sounds are probably the most
important way we judge any value
judgment that anyone is proposing in a
project
do you want to add more to that
ginsengers go to the line yeah I suppose
that afterwards that Gary my head was
were making I'll try our hardest to make
sure that as many beneficial things come
out of the projects as possible for all
as many people with as involved that's
for us individually but also for client
youth future user and that might be that
might require different responses for
different projects foot to it too to
enable that kind of generals to the
generosity means different things in
different projects I suppose another way
of putting it it could be it could be
about the budget it could just purely be
about getting the best out of a small
budget yeah most of our projects so far
have been very low budget very tight
situation and so you the appropriateness
is very much to sign by the available
tools available materials so the example
of mechanistic approach of making an
event space if you're creating something
that has to provide a theatre space with
all the nuts and pubs the paraphernalia
to have lights like then anything you
add to that it seems to make sense to do
it off the available kit whereas if
you're trying to make a really rich
lovely school space you use an available
under spare and the stair or a bit round
the corner or tucked under there so it
really is making do in many ways it's a
question here in the mic
I um thinking about that case of the
Christmas decorations outside of the
lawns I was wondering whether you've
encountered all in this participatory
idea of you know giving people control
over their own environment and how then
that reality of the home depot is sort
of the power structures and the market
and maybe limited resources in actual
context how do you approach that in your
your designs or have you encountered any
sort of you know complications with this
I think a great idea of sort of you know
bringing giving individual expression
back to the environment crown terrace is
a good example people to get this
picture up edge and a projector on just
perhaps yeah but also the other housing
schemes have been even talked about in
that the think the residents can quite
clearly benefit almost immediately from
that situation compared to being in a
much more constrained rented
accommodation or or given accommodation
from a very social landlord the
difficulty or the debate that comes out
of that conversation is how you control
that is one of the biggest bugbears of
people who manage accommodation is how
people miss you space rather than how
people user base a lot of that is anti
socialness to do with people doing
inappropriate things and corridors or
what have you but other bits are about
when people just let their lifestyle
kind of hang out terrorists a bit too
much try and put washing machines out
there or store nine bikes on the balcony
or whatever whatever they do and I think
that's where we came up where where we
by having that level of questioning from
listed social animals and within
ourselves of how we ended up with a
strategy where you look to provide quite
formal urban front or strong front to
those proposals and allow the looseness
to happen behind that facade so it's
almost slightly
slightly conduct that inevitability of
people doing whatever they like means
that you need some kind of device that
gives it a consistent edge oh I would
add to that and this is largely a
theoretical concern because for one
boring reason and another are more than
one family home housing never seems to
get built but one thing that comes at
time and time again when we're weighing
it up is that we're adamant that it
mustn't be necessary for someone to have
to do any form of personalization or
appropriating for that place to be a
good place to live in that we don't want
to assume anyone has the resources
either financial or money to do so so
imbalance or either financial time to do
so so in developing the designs it's
often been to that point where there is
something to be added to and yet it
would never feel that you were living in
a bleep unfinished space response for
comment earlier about the corbu Xion
neutrality with this project we wanted
to create a relatively strong neutral
civic front but we thought the personal
space it could be what it could be
neutral but actually if you make each
one individual and have its own
character and material decoration then
you're actively encouraging people to
change it if they want and so I guess
that's the difference perhaps between
our starting point and Kobes IAM trying
to give more of a catalyst to change the
starting point if you create something
it's slightly more heterogeneous very to
start with then hopefully it will it's
more likely to change there's a
architecture in England call Peter
barber who does housing it's not a
million miles from this but it's all
white and he shares many of our beliefs
and wanting change to happen because his
buildings are all white no one changes
them and so 10 years down the line 15
years down i and i still feel exactly
the same so I guess that's generosity
trying to make things that people feel
they can change in a way that won't be
intrusive upon their Navy are there are
some more questions yes
absa Neil and then would you Patrick
yeah um well Jeff I think in your in
your talk you very modestly prefer to
yourselves as cut and paste architects
and I thought it was interesting how
then showing that stare there was this
kind of incredible range of I guess
technological sophistication in terms
there are technical technological
processes that went from formwork to
laser cutting and so I was just
wondering as architects of you know your
generation how you see not so much just
the content of sampling but technologies
of sampling which are very good are
potentially very contemporary
technologies not just in the how your
leads to it you know the production of
your work or how your work comes out but
even the technologies of participation
that might you know how you see that as
something that might further your work
in the future we are very interested in
easing technology by possible but it's
again frequently driven by appropriately
so one of the reasons we did a laser cut
stairs because it's actually a really
cheap way makes is down and in loads of
very low budget schools we're doing now
we've managed commits contractor that we
can have the stairs any shape we want
because we can laser cut them be cheaper
so that's a very practical take
technology the technology with regards
to participation is intriguing because
obviously the last ten years has been
explosion of technologies that allow
people to communicate in different ways
and that might be ideal for
participatory processes have been
planning meetings in second life people
have tweeted about various projects in
cetera et cetera but we have found it
and you perhaps you were to talk
wireless but traditionally always come
back to participate resent getting
people in a room and having a
conversation being far more useful than
any removed that well in the end it's
the quality of the conversation that
matters and again we're often operating
in very low resource situations so at
the moment there's tremendous potential
in terms of technology for people
planning and designing together but then
actually looking back at that jana
friedman diagram has been tremendous
potential for decades but actually if
you've got very few resources just
having some pens and paper but really
investing your time and thinking about
how group dynamics work and the ways in
which you can draw out a conversation
and manage conflict you can get a lot
more done just by convincing people to
come together for a few hours in a room
and work so now I think we're Luddites
but again we're it perhaps a symptom of
the low resource environments we tend to
operate judging technology based upon
use Robin innovation I think the one
that's best hours the technologies of
sampling and itself as a way of scanning
replicating things and I think I think
again that is probably at the moment
particularly just driven by budget and
opportunity in terms of the word we
presented and I think that I guess some
of the unbuilt work suggests that we
might have required that so the burn bet
project may have may have required some
kind of way of laser scanning a mountain
or something you know I think that's
that's that's will come will come when
it can maybe we haven't we guess we try
as in that many times as possible to
engage with pragmatic kind of real
situations or would very definitely take
brief seriously when they have budgets
with them and within them which is
climbing unlike some of our
contemporaries who quite often use a
competition opportunity to not relate to
the budget sometimes I work sometimes it
doesn't yeah obviously sometimes if you
blow the budget that's the way to win
the job and way to execute work quite
often you win the competition and then
don't execute work I guess we struggled
to not tear the budget
the architecture building was won by
another architect very well known yeah
and will not be built we were told to de
casa yeah no competition scheme looked
very expensive han wasn't built because
it was too expensive bad break thanks
sorry to to raise the local Busey again
but I'm that that image kind of shows
how the priority of modernism sort of
the visual sense or the ocular sense of
the other building ocular syx aspects of
design prioritize prioritized in
modernism when you work but when you
start to do your deep digging into what
people really want in buildings can you
sort of an idea what proportion of the
responses you get our visual and what
proportion of the responses you get
relate to the other senses the perhaps
the less visual sensors and how do you
transform that into architecture when
it's non visual that responding to galen
about me I'll do areas rather we in the
London context where we work I'd say
there is an equal interest in how things
look which is often quite a conservative
interest although a conservative
interest that can quickly with towards a
quite British eccentricity and then a
real functionalist in peak that
obviously you'll be aware that
architects don't have a particularly
good rep among non-professional to take
ordinary people as if architects aren't
ordinary but in the UK and so people
will always feel that an architect that
there are very few examples for example
of good recent housing around that
people can afford so people will be
cynical we when we r then working brief
building with people we really push
people to think about space with all
their senses so we will always when
we're going in particularly with
refurbishment projects rather than just
sit in a room to discuss the brief and
set priorities we take everyone out and
I make a fool of myself getting them to
smell and move and breathin but
everything that actually makes you see
you space in you and think well what can
we learn from this about things we've
got to keep and things we'd want
to change the children are a lot better
at it a lot better doing it a baby
immediately yeah but i actually prefer
working with adults because i just those
children yeah i think you can do in the
UK i don't know if it's the same here
there's such a huge cynicism from
professionals in turn about what
non-professionals are capable of
thinking about and they very quickly get
dismissed as their contributions won't
be appropriate or they will be
conservative or cliched and it doesn't
take much effort just to treat people
like the adults they are and to give
them the confidence to start expressing
their opinions and ask them the
questions that provoke interesting
answers and time and time again people
surprised yes by actually we start the
process way that they think about things
they start the process hating everything
in the world other than their school
whatever it looks like and at the end of
the process they are completely in love
with Daisy and I'm the architecture
choices that we make schools are also
interesting because last for public
three public school projects we've done
every time we started presents the
client priorities what we think of their
priorities they gradually shift around
and gradually the most important thing
that rises up is that the classrooms are
well-lit and naturally ventilated and
well proportioned and this grossly comes
up and up until it's at the top and the
wow entrance garage leasing expansion
they kind of spectacular feature there
can i gradually comes down and you
realize that at the end of the day the
biggest one is feel kind of getting the
basics right and that is as much about
visuals as it is about quality of air
etc try immersion is where Patrick might
have been slightly
hahaha is there another burning question
in the house or not burning right there
ah Joel Sanders we have to get the mic
back to you hold your fire is that
warming I think you'll find the
distinction between architect and real
people very useful and going forward so
first I just wanted to begin by saying
it's hard enough but for a single
lecturer to deliver a coherent lecture
and here's the four of you coordinating
to give one engaged lively lecture with
a narrative thread that we all got
thematically which is really terrific
and I commend you for that my question
though has to do maybe a little bit
related to Ed's question is is how do
you marry your very provocative name of
your firm agents of change with your
interest in the quotidian the familiar
and historical references at the risk of
generalization you know I think we often
associate architecture with that makes
references to the to the familiar with a
kind of interest in a kind of maybe
perhaps a reproduction of traditional
values or of the status quo where your
work seems if I'm interpreting correctly
to be very much about instigating
alternative modes of social interaction
so I'm just very very curious and and I
think it's fascinating it's how do you
almost reconcile these opposites the the
traditional too familiar the vernacular
and this interest in the instigation of
change I think that man growing his tree
in his front garden is a really good
example of something deeply everyday
deeply familiar and yet amazing the idea
of ever drawing anything half out good
so many other people turning their
living room into the par surface I the
everyday is a very very misuse and idea
one of the things we're very keen to
emphasise
is that we're interesting I wouldn't say
only every day because we are
individuals that have our own placed but
in quite a very broad range at every day
and we're constantly amazed at how weird
and wonderful and utterly unfamiliar
that every day is there's a certain
school of architecture has become
associated with the everyday that tends
to take a very kind of 2% very refined
Wisteria came back to the those words
again but we assuming there is a tension
that isn't reconciled and again it's
something that we're getting a chance to
explore bit more with the seminar series
here but obviously you do have the
tension between the kind of support and
interest we have four practices of DIY
and christmas decoration and then
knowing full well that those can easily
be seen is the sort of participative
practices that distract people from
addressing the bigger social structures
and orders where they might be able to
effect change because they're so busy
changing away within the established
ones that where society likes to keep
them held I don't think we personally
have resolved that tension but one thing
that we're quite conscious of and I mean
really were kind of at the spotty
teenager phase of being a practice now
is that when we set up as agents of
change we were kids we were well we
wouldn't we were people who are jobs
that paid us money in other contexts and
we were able to enter kind of our Jean
provocateur tight competitions that were
about and a lot of the game work really
came out of that ways of making
revealing structures and make people
thinking actually doesn't have to be
this way we now are at the stage where
we have a reasonably large office to
support and the limited opportunity of
jobs that are available for architects
in the UK and at the moment we really
are going through a values assessment I
guess just thinking wanting to make sure
we have our moral rather set straight in
terms of the kind of ongoing work that
will take and being able to weigh up the
vent do the benefits of this job
outweigh the limitations of it but then
but I would emphasize once again that we
we are not agents of change
that is and deliberately we were never
always going to be it we were always a
OC because we wanted the potential to
change as well so we knew when you we're
going to sell out one day and it was
really important I mean next time they
come there will be called Skidmore
Owings